okay bismillah 20 minutes two cakes
let's go
we got it all right so what are we doing
first we're doing the eggs first right
yeah let's go let's do it all right
oh snap okay and now we have the
chocolate right no no no no no flour
flour flour no it's too flat
it's chocolate you don't put chocolate
in it everyone knows you pick chocolate
what do you mean do it
it's chocolate what are you doing yo
it's not it's chocolate it's
not chocolate it's chocolate it's
chocolate spoon it's chocolate it's
chocolate look
trust me it's chocolate it's gonna be
chocolate you gotta do this
[Music]
five hours later thank you for the
recipes my mother the cakes were just
amazing
thank you i love you speak to you soon
we did it bro
i could have just called her four hours
ago it can take over 20 years for a
great cook to perfect his award-winning
cake recipe
it just takes 20 minutes to teach his
apprentice someone can pass on all of
the years of experience
education and the lessons they have
learned to their student and in the
process
develop and empower them to achieve
greater success
this is exactly what we want to do at
sapience institute
our team has over 100 years of
collective experience in intellectually
sharing islam
more postgraduate degrees than the
thermometer many years of learning
lessons from mistakes and challenges
and we have hundreds of hours of
educational experience
training and developing thousands of
people around the world
including scholars activists and imams
last ramadan we promised to record and
publish 10
courses on our learning platform of
which you are now
seeing unseen unpublished footage
develop a book on doubts
professionally film a course on dealing
with doubts record and publish over 60
videos
publish books and articles and expand
our free
lighthouse mentoring service
alhamdulillah
we are well on our way to achieve our
targets however
we need your support to do more and make
greater impact the da'wah deserves the
best
and there's so much to do in these
blessed days of dulhija
where the reward for these during the
day are more rewardable than the days of
ramadan
you have the opportunity to support this
much needed
and noble work help us create support
and develop a new generation of people
to intellectually and academically share
islam
click the button or go to the link below
and donate
now and don't forget to share this video
[Music]
that tastes like 100 years of experience
right there man
so good
[Music]